we have listed here we know that carbon
12 is the most common isotope of carbon
on earth ninety eight point eight nine
percent of the carbon on earth is
carbon-12 and we know that by definition
its mass is exactly 12 atomic mass units
now that's not the only isotope of
carbon on earth there are other isotopes
the next most frequent one is frequent
one is carbon 13 one point one one
percent of the carbon on earth is carbon
13 and we can experimentally find that
its mass is 13 point zero zero three for
atomic mass units so these numbers that
we have here just as a review these are
atomic mass these are atomic mass and so
we're going to think about in this video
as well how do they come up with the
atomic weight number that they'll give
you on a periodic table like that so
atomic atomic weight where it is where
does that come from well in the video on
atomic weight and on atomic mass we see
that the atomic weight is the weighted
average of the atomic masses of the
various isotopes of that element so to
find this roughly 12.01 we take the
weighted average of these two things and
what are we weighted by will we wait
about we weighted by how common that
that isotope actually is so what we want
to do is we could take ninety eight
point eight nine percent and multiply it
by twelve and I'll rewrite this
percentage as a decimal so it'll be zero
point nine eight eight nine times twelve
and to that we are going to add we are
going to add one point one one percent
times thirteen point zero zero three
four so as a decimal that's going to be
zero point zero one one per or that's
one point one one percent is zero point
zero one one oh one one one and I'm
going to multiply that times thirteen
point zero zero three four
atomic mass units so what does that give
us let's get our calculator out here so
we are going to have zero point nine
eight eight nine times 12 is equal to
eleven point eight six six eight and to
that we are going to add we are going to
add zero point zero one one one times
thirteen point zero zero three four and
I know it's going to do this
multiplication first because the
calculator knows about order of
operations and so that's all going to be
as you can see twelve point zero one one
one three seven seven four which if you
were to round to the hundreds place is
how this this atomic weight was gotten
so that's hat there you go that's how we
calculate atomic weight so I could write
this as approximately twelve point zero
one it's the weighted average of the
atomic masses now another thing that you
might want to note is what's the
difference between carbon-12 and
carbon-13 carbon-12 this right over here
is six protons the six protons are what
make it carbon so both of these will
have six protons and the difference is
in the neutrons this right over here has
six neutrons six neutrons and this right
over here is going to have one more
Neutron seven neutrons so when you look
at the difference in atomic mass notice
the change is looks like it's plus one
point zero zero three for atomic mass
units so from this you can see hey look
if I add a neutron plus one Neutron plus
one Neutron it's roughly equal to an
atomic mass unit it's not exactly an
atomic mass unit but roughly speaking a
lot of kind of very broad high-level
terms you can kind of view it as being
very close to one atomic mass unit and
the same thing is true of protons but
anyway hopefully you now have
appreciation for the difference between
atomic mass which is the mass and atomic
weight which is the weighted average of
the various isotopes of that element on
earth how to calculate it and roughly
what the mass of a neutron
News